RUSSIAN ELECTION, WHAT I SEE IS
A LACK OF CREDIBILITY.
SO CARL ICAHN WOULDN'T HAVE BEEN
HIGH ON MY LIST.
>> Bret: THE PRESIDENT MEETING
WITH A SAUDI CONFERENCE AT THE
WHITE HOUSE TODAY BUT THE
HEADLINE ENDED UP BEING HIS CALL
WITH A PUTIN.
CONGRATULATING RUSSIAN LEADER ON
HIS ELECTION WON WHICH IS NOT A
SURPRISE.
IT GOT A LOT OF REACTION.
HERE IN WASHINGTON AND ARIZONA.
HERE SENATOR McCAIN'S
STATEMENT.
AN AMERICAN PRESIDENT DOES NOT
LEAD THE FREE WORLD BY
CONGRATULATING DICTATORS
UNWITTING SHAM ELECTION.
HE INSULTED EVERY RUSSIAN
CITIZEN THAT WAS DENIED THE
RIGHT TO VOTE IN A FREE AND FAIR
ELECTION TO DETERMINE THEIR
COUNTRY'S FUTURE, INCLUDING THE
COUNTLESS RUSSIAN PATRIOTS WHO
HAVE RISKED SO MUCH TO PROTEST
AND RESIST PUTIN'S REGIME.
WITH THAT, LET'S BRING IN OUR
PANEL.
JONAH GOLDBERG, SENIOR EDITOR AT
"NATIONAL REVIEW."
AMY WALTER, NATIONAL EDITOR, AND
BEN DOMENECH, PUBLISHER AT "THE
FEDERALIST."
BEN, THOUGHTS ON THE REACTION?
A LOT OF IT HERE IN WASHINGTON
TO THIS STATEMENT AND
MISCOMMUNICATION.
>> IT'S A DIFFERENT SITUATION
I'M IN TERMS OF THE RELATIONSHIP
WITH RUSSIA THEN IT WAS SEVERAL
YEARS AGO WHEN WE SAW
PRESIDENT OBAMA GIVING
CONGRATULATIONS TO PUTIN
OVER A RECENT ELECTION.
THIS IS A SITUATION THAT I THINK
IS GOING TO TURN INTO ITS OWN
SORT OF FORM OF A RESET, WRITE
ATTEMPT BY THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION TO ENGAGE IN THAT
BEHAVIOR OBVIOUSLY, THEY WANT TO
GET RID OF THIS INVESTIGATION
THAT HAS BEEN ONGOING, THEY
WANTED TO COME TO A CONCLUSION
AND THEY WANT TO TALK TO PUTIN
ABOUT A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
FACTORS.
THE DOMESTIC SCENARIO HERE, THE
SITUATION IN WASHINGTON, REALLY
HASN'T ALLOWED THEM TO DO THAT
YET.
>> Bret: AMY?
>> IT IS VERY DIFFERENT FROM THE
TERM OF OBAMA, EVEN VERY
DIFFERENT FROM A VERY COUPLE
MONTHS AGO.
THIS IS NO LONGER ABOUT RUSSIA
MEDDLING IN THE ELECTION, WE ARE
NOT TALKING ABOUT POISONING IN
BRITAIN, WE HAVE NOT HAD
DISCUSSIONS YET ON THAT.
APPARENTLY THE PRESIDENT DID NOT
RAISE THAT ISSUE WITH BOUDIN.
I THINK THIS IS ONE OF THOSE
ISSUES THAT HAS BEEN ONGOING
SINCE THE PRESIDENT HAS GOTTEN
INTO TOWN THAT DIVIDES THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY, MUCH THE WAY
THE ISSUE OF TRADE DIVIDES THE
PARTY, THAT YOU ARE GOING TO
HAVE FOLKS IN THE CAMP THAT SAY
THERE SHOULD BE ABSOLUTELY NO
RELATIONSHIP WITH BOUDIN.
HE'S A BAD DUDE.
DON'T EVER TRY TO MAKE THIS
RELATIONSHIP WORK, AND FOLKS
THAT ARE ALIGNED WITH THE
PRESIDENT WHO DO YOU WANT TO SEE
SOMETHING HAPPEN.
BUT THE BOTTOM LINE IS, THERE'S
A WHOLE LOT OF THIS HAPPENING
EVEN IN THE LAST COUPLE OF
MONTHS, THE FACT OF THE
PRESIDENT DIDN'T RAISE THAT I
THINK IS A GOOD PART OF THE
REASON WHY SO MANY REPUBLICANS
ARE WORRIED.
>> Bret: HE'S TALKING ABOUT
THE POISONING IN GREAT BRITAIN,
THE SANCTIONS THAT THIS REGIME,
THIS ADMINISTRATION HAS PUT ON
THE RUSSIAN REGIME.
IT DOESN'T TALK ABOUT THAT'S.
>> THERE SINCE WE ARE DOUBLE
GAME, OR THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
BEEN QUITE TOUGH ON RUSSIA.
DONALD TRUMP HAS NOT BEEN
RHETORICALLY.
IT SETS PEOPLE OFF AROUND
WASHINGTON BECAUSE OF ALL THE
OTHER BAGGAGE THAT WE WERE
REFERRING TO.
I AGREE WITH A LOT OF THINGS,